dream of working at Google well here are
five reasons working there kind of sucks
you're there forever need a haircut
gourmet food a massage a bus Google
provides its employees with everything
they'll ever need for free so you'll
never have a reason to leave work ever
your company is sketch with user privacy
in 2013 the Snowden leaks revealed that
Google worked directly with the NSA's
prism surveillance program take that
customer satisfaction your genius gets
paid but not always used being at the
top of your MIT class might mean getting
paid 128 thousand dollars for working on
projects like Google Plus your skin
color and ovaries might get in the way
being a woman or ethnic minority in tech
means you probably won't love your white
male work environments you'll never be
the best Google hires the best of the
best the chances of you being the best
of the best of the best aren't worth
thinking about
but hey you're still working where
everyone else wishes they worked
you